oh
i think we both want to put an end to
the bloodshed
mostly because we want to go eat fried
fish and drink white wine together
huzzah with a saffron aioli yes larvae
only and as neither of these old can win
nor do they seem able to lose
we should come to a deal we are again
shut up
agreed
you have sway with
poland and with denmark of course
they love me
i suspect you wishes to seek an end to
the trade embargo with was i talking to
you
manage your people say peter hola shut
up
yes of course we can and you must [ __ ]
off out of
you know where is it
russia yeah
i will move my men out of cairo this is
capitulation we own that chatty sanders
yes
i thought this would be difficult but
actually negotiations are easy maybe i'm
just good at it you know i say what i
want you say what you want and we both
agree huzzah huzzah
and of course in petersburg
what
it's in petersburg i say again what and
you shall note the shift in my tone
i know it seems big but
some petersburg was always swedish
for 400 years
until your father stole it from us 30
years ago stole it uh he
won it you [ __ ] lost it and then he
turned a [ __ ] hole into a grand city
i know you don't want to live under the
past glories and failures of your father
peter honestly as your friend
if you seek a clean slate as emperor the
best thing for you to do is to give some
petersburg up huge
why are you ruining everything that city
is a monstrous shadow it's his city
it's his victory none of it yours all of
it
contextualizing you as a
puny leader of skinny achievement
did you just call me puny
no but
when placed against him of course it
looks that way
ask your people what
[ __ ]
i'm you are it ah
you and he thanks for making my point
blaster guts
now you go to moscow
you make that your base
that is the new center of russia from
there you can be your own man you could
be your own emperor
and build your own russia
i'm doing you a favor here
it's interesting yeah
we'll just think on it for a moment okay
here's your peace deal
suck on that
you're biting me
[Music]
it's frustrating to wait outside the
doors is it not you would rather witness
their idiocy
i would you
swedish
you're gonna drown in the blood of your
people i'm sorry you feel that way
mama's boy you know my father [ __ ]
your mother in the face after a state
dinner in the face
there's 30 million of us and only two
million of you i don't care if four
million of us have to die to kill two
million of you we're russian we don't
give off how many of us die what has
happened
empress your husband is afraid if this
is news i apologize although i doubt it
is does this mean lunch is cancelled and
me you against a tree also cancelled
we're leaving
[Music]
you